what happens when a conspiracy theorist
was right all along beneath the surface
level fun of Netflix's monster movie
troll there are some big ideas to unpack
spoilers ahead
there are scores of films that introduce
a monster or Fantastical creature into a
world that is otherwise completely
grounded in reality an inevitable plot
Point becomes the character's reaction
to this creature existing and them
getting over the hurdle of thinking it's
merely fiction such is the case with
troll which spends a great deal of its
run time convincing its characters of
its own mythology the Norwegian
government enlists professional
assistance from Nora Tiedeman in
identifying the source of massive
footprint-shaped markings Nora's father
Tobias insists they're not just
footprint shaped but actual Footprints
belonging to a troll as a little girl
Nora used to love her father's Tales of
Norway's Trolls but now she takes a more
logical approach to life in the end
though Tobias is right in a way this
component of troll almost mirrors A
variation of the archetype scene and
many Christmas films in which characters
begrudgingly deny Santa's existence only
to eventually come around in the end and
believe in him the difference in troll
though is that the payoff for its
fantasy being real all along isn't some
fluffy warm holiday moment for the
characters role accepting the reality
that Trolls Exist means facing a very
real threat to the Natural order of
their world it's an eerie juxtaposition
to consider the Fulfillment of childhood
fantasies leading to imminent Doom
relationships between kids and their
parents can become complicated as kids
become adults Nora used to hang on to
tobias's every word as they adventured
together across the mountains they
imagined themselves as Heroes of a
fictional Quest called The Adventures of
big and Tiny and these moments together
were the core of their relationship
following the death of Nora's Mom though
Nora and Tobias grew apart the action of
troll begins years after this incident
in time to see them somewhat make amends
just before the troll kills Tobias Nora
spends the remainder of the film
grappling with the concept of her
father's Legacy you do know that
there's some truth to every fairy tale
within the ebb and flow of Nora's
relationship with her father the
audience might consider their own
relationships with their parental
figures what leads to estrangement to
family members who were once so close
how does one approach reconciliation
when both parties are responsible for
the falling out how does one honor the
memory of a lost loved one when they may
not fully believe in everything the
person stood for Nora finds closure and
healing in her relationship with Tobias
in the wake of tobias's death even if
Tobias didn't live to see Nora come
around to his point of view his
preparation while still living made it
possible in the first place fulfilling
his Mantra that the incredible isn't
impossible
Andreas is the prime minister's
assistant he keeps the prime minister's
schedule on track and is involved in
most of her day-to-day activities but
stays noticeably and intentionally on
the sidelines despite this Andreas
occasionally speaks his mind even if the
situation doesn't directly call for his
input as the Prime Minister reviews
footage of the trolls Footprints while
the markings Origins are still unknown
Andreas suggests to her that they look
foot shaped
like Footprints right later in a room
full of government officials Andreas
sits in an Outer Circle of chairs
against the far edge of the wall away
from the people participating in the
conversation despite the fact that he's
an obvious Outsider he speaks up again
or Supernatural Andreas is a consistent
reminder that an individual's influence
should not be dictated by the level of
status associated with their station of
work Andreas is an assistant and yet in
the fight to save the country from the
Troll's destruction he proves to be one
of the most valuable voices involved
without him many more people would have
died
as a mountaineer who mostly keeps to
himself and whose knowledge of trolls
ends up being correct tobias's Arc
proves to be an interesting character
study in as his daughter Nora puts it
the difference between having an
imagination and losing touch with
reality Tobias lives alone in the middle
of nowhere the walls of his house are
plastered with maps and newspaper
clippings as if he's tracing a crime and
he indignantly implores everyone to
believe that trolls are real why would
we never taught the trolls actually
exist its conspiracy theorist 101 except
that in this case tobias's hunches
aren't theories at all he's correct in
his assumptions lending a nuanced
thematic layer to the story despite
tobias's expertise about the lay of the
land in which the trolls markings were
spotted everyone is quick to write off
his claim that the markings actually
belong to a real troll later of course
they realize that the seemingly crazy
guy had been right all along not only
that but history was much darker than
even Tobias thought with the entire
troll race being eradicated and buried
underground with only one of them
remaining alive what are the
repercussions of labeling someone too
quickly how does a fundamental change in
a philosophical perspective shift one's
approach to life going forward these
questions hit Nora hard especially in
the aftermath of her father's sudden
death
as Tobias attempts to approach the troll
calmly members of the Norwegian military
immediately engaged in combat prompting
retaliation from the troll this sets
into motion the entire second half of
the film effectively becoming a troll
versus Humans war in retrospect one
can't help but wonder how the ending
would have been different if the
military personnel had resisted the urge
to take that first shot surely the troll
wouldn't have killed Tobias moments
later how much progress would Tobias
have been able to make in his effort to
begin friendly relations with the troll
maybe even leading to a new era of
society the incident brings to mind the
implications of handling conflict in
different ways Tobias advocates for
trying to see the troll as a living
creature and empathizing with it before
immediately resorting to combat we can
scare it with weapons we can push it
around but I I promise Nora nature will
push back while admittedly a big leap
for others to make when the troll is
capable of destroying everything in its
path there are assumptions about the
Troll's intentions become a
self-fulfilling prophecy since they
believed the troll would harm them they
tried to hurt it before it got the
chance and in doing so created the
monster they feared it didn't have to be
that way
Nora's dreams were as Fantastical as her
father's when she was a little girl as
an adult though she pursues the more
grounded scientific version of troll
chasing by being a paleontologist the
role translates Nora's childhood fantasy
into a career but it's based more on
rationale and logic than what was
previously an unbridled love for
adventure similarly Andreas has dreams
of being a writer but life's gotten in
the way and his current station is
assistant to the Prime Minister it's
certainly a dignified job but it's got
nothing to do with his true passion
Nora's career as a paleontologist in
andreas's career in the Norwegian
government are both different from how
they thought their adult lives would end
up toward the end of the film Andreas
quits his job to pursue writing perhaps
the ultimate embodiment of the 180 and
artists Journey sometimes takes there's
no concrete indication that Nora will
quit paleontology but she's definitely
been philosophically changed by her
experience with the Troll And even if
she stays in the same profession she
will undoubtedly approach it differently
as both characters step forward into new
chapters of their lives they are
examples of contrasting choices that
that the audience can perhaps relate to
finding a solution to restlessness by
deciding that a drastic change is in
order or deciding to do the same thing
in a new way
in discussing how to eliminate the
threat of the troll in Norway the Prime
Minister meets with military personnel
they inform her that nuclear missiles
are an option which the prime minister
is startled to learn are available why
wasn't I informed of this before
untested and not fully ready for use the
missiles would put nearby civilians In
Harm's Way if deployed this information
of course is spared from public
disclosure painting a picture of a
government that isn't completely honest
with its citizens and at times isn't
even completely honest with its own
leaders during the climax of the film
The missiles are inevitably authorized
but secret a low-ranking government
employee and a friend of Andreas
sabotages the plan at the last moment
saving countless lives Sigrid breaking
protocol to stand up for what she
believes in follows the typical movie
formula of an underdog giving a corrupt
government what for a signature move of
disaster films elsewhere the government
is able to hack into a random civilian's
phone to obtain a video with evidence of
the Troll's existence Sigrid mentions
the hack was complicated but not
impossible throughout troll the
government almost acts as a care
character unto itself aligning with the
dark overreaching personality that many
films assign to governments of any
country
Tobias notes that folklorists made up
lies about trolls to always depict them
negatively in Generations old stories
which led to stereotypes against the
creatures in the present these
generalizations undoubtedly lead to many
of the humans assumptions about the last
remaining troll when they discover its
existence if you tell a lie enough times
people take it as the truth ah the
Eggheads it it's an applicable social
commentary that's sure to be noticed by
the audience especially in an age when
misinformation spreads like wildfire
perhaps smartly the script refrains from
having Andreas interject any specific
example into his introspection he
doesn't for example insert a topical
reference to covid-19 or an election
which might have tipped the point toward
being more distracting than effective
instead the viewers can simply fill in
the blanks themselves
by the film's climax all of tobias's
hypotheses about the trolls have turned
out to be true even in death his
knowledge guides Nora's Mission and in a
crucial moment she remembers one last
bit of info that could help defeat the
troll for good in folklore trolls are
averse to sunlight Nora realizes that
while she's seen the troll during the
daytime the sky has always been cloudy
we've seen him during the day
but have we seen him in direct sunlight
the sun has never been out at the same
time as the troll so there's reason to
believe that the old belief might be
true even though it's nighttime if she
can lure the troll to an area where
artificial sunlight can shine in its
face she just might save everyone from
the trolls destruction her plan works
but she soon puts two and two together
to discover the light won't stop the
troll without killing it Nora pulls the
plug on the operation to kill the troll
at the last minute wanting to follow in
her late Father's Footsteps and try to
approach the troll peacefully the
repercussions of this Choice while Noble
and the right thing to do would have no
doubt been a much harder path forward
the community at large would face major
societal roadblocks and how to
communicate with and accommodate the
coexistence of humans with the troll in
a polite symbiosis which surely would
also have its fair share of naysayers to
deal with it would change everything
regardless Norris heroism is rendered
null when the sun immediately Rises and
kills the troll the story redeems Nora's
intentions while still taking the easy
way out
a plot Point that's Central to the
entire film is that the troll roaming
about is the last of its kind in
existence this discovery is what makes
the cover-up of the underground
Mausoleum of troll skeletons
semi-plausible it also helps Nora and
the audience lend a greater sense of
empathy to the troll if it's the only
one left of course it's lonely and it
makes sense that it would be confused
and destructive it has no one and it's
this train of thought that leads to Nora
wanting to save it in the end a
mid-credit scene indicates there's at
least one more troll alive with the
camera showing a giant creature
violently emerging from seemingly the
same cave where the original troll came
from this twist while leaving the door
wide open for a sequel paints The
Narrative of most of this first film In
a Different Light if there was more than
one troll all along then much of the
explanation that the movie provides for
its narrative needs revising this would
surely be explained should a follow-up
come about but it would feel a bit odd
considering the lengths to which the
first film goes to establish its lore
[Music]
foreign